فرزه اردوغان طبعا
معناته استمرار النموذج التركي نموذج
اردوغاني وتركيا تستمر بقوه اذا تصويت على
الاستقرار
والتنميه
وزن
[موسيقى]
الوزراء ما بين الاكراد والاتراك وايضا من
الشرق والغرب والجنوب الى اخره في توازن
في تشكيله الحكومه الجديده بالخبره ايضا
تكنوقراطيين ايضا
من الحزب يعني مثلا
نائب الرئيس
جوده يلماس السيد جبل ماز له خبره طويله
وهو دائما يعني كان معه والان سيشرف على
على مساعده او سياخذ منصب نائب للرئيس
وهذا خبره له يعني هو رجل تكنوقراطي رجل
ايضا سياسي رجل له خبره
وايضا
قبول يعني
نفس الشيء مع تعيين رئيس تعيين الوزير
الخارجيه تعيين الوزير الخارجيه كان في
ذنب من رئيس
المخابرات السابق وايضا موضوع مهم لان
خبره كثيره في طبعا هناك ازمات وهناك
تحولات كثيره وفي كل حال يعني السياسه
الخارجي ايضا مرتبطه بسياسه
الامنيه بسياسات الامنيه وهذا
اعتقد له خبره طويله
تعيين يليق يا وزير الداخليه ايضا مهم جدا
لانك عنده خبره
كسب خبره طويله في اذا في الجنوب قبل
اسطنبول لكن في اسطنبول ايضا هو
تعامل مع المواضيع الامنيه
واللاجئين اعتقد يعني سيكون في موضوع لاجئ
سيكون تهدئه لان هذا الموضوع مسيس اكثر من
من لازم بعد الانتخابات سينحفظ يعني
اهتمام بهذا الموضوع ويعني يكون تدابير
امنيه والمحاربه الارهاب هو محاربه
الارهاب محاربه الاجرام في في المدن
الكبيره مهمه جدا
لتعيينها سيسهل في هذا المجال
[موسيقى]
تعيين محمد شمس وزير الماليه مهم جدا لان
له ايضا خبره طويله وايضا مصداقيه عاليه
في السوق العالمي في رايه هو يكون يعني
اداه النجاح سيوازن مع احتياجات الداخل
والخارج وهذا اعتقد كسب بالنسبه لتركيا
وبالنسبه للحكومه الجديده هذا الخبره طبعا
سيعكس على السياسات واقتصاد تركي اصلا
قويه قوي وستستمر في نفس الاتجاه مركز على
الانتاج على الصناعه على السياحه الزراعه
الى اخره والتجاره
[موسيقى]